oh jesus
ghost tv shows and movies are full of
jump scares and scenes that have us
watching through the cracks between our
fingers
it's all part of the fun but we
discovered actors from huge shows and
films
like stranger things and harry potter
were just as terrified during the
filming of those scenes
from intense method acting haunted set
locations and even actors facing their
deepest phobias
we're uncovering just what scenes from
your favorite movies and tv
shows left cast members petrified
seriously i could just do like a whole
bowl of nougat
we were all on the edge of our seats
when eleven ventured into the void to
try and find heather the lifeguard in
stranger things season 3.
we might have thought the scene was
intense but for heather's actress
francesca real
it was horrifying doing the drowning was
actually in a pool with a black bottom
which was terrifying for me
the moment katniss sees peeta's sunken
face on tv
after he's abducted by the capital is
dark
what's even more heartbreaking is that
katniss's reaction is
actually how jennifer lawrence responded
to seeing the video for the first time
the director knew j law hadn't seen josh
hutcherson in a while
and if she was shocked with the video
they'd be able to capture her genuine
fear
on camera talk about intense method
acting
are you there for the most part the
euphoria cast seemed to have an amazing
time on set
except on their last filming day of
season one when they were on location at
an abandoned mental hospital that had
shut down after 40 patients
lost their lives there was even a morgue
actress sydney sweeney is still not over
the spookiness
it was the creepiest place that i'd ever
been to and we were filming there
all day and all night dude you were good
on that and he was just like
we all know that the cranks from maze
runner are just a combination of
talented actors and makeup artists but
that didn't stop dylan o'brien and
thomas sangster from genuinely being
afraid to film with them
take a listen the the little guy
oh he was terrified yeah in a twisted
way their fear
probably made the final cut even more
realistic
for voldemort the harry potter casting
directors had to make sure they brought
on an actor
who did intimidating well they succeeded
not only was ray fine
scary as voldemort but daniel radcliffe
says that he was terrified any time he
had a scene with rafe
i remember when i was 15 doing the
scenes with rafe for the first time
he was even scarier than alan was at
first rafe genuinely scared me for a few
years
you cry for that the witchy vibes and
the chilling adventures of sabrina
weren't always the greatest
the showrunners were dedicated to making
sure that all the pagan rituals were
done
accurately which made it a little too
real for actress tati gabriel who played
prudence
she always feared that they would
actually be calling out to the
supernatural
i do smudging just to keep my energy
clear when we step
off like let's leave that behind yikes
was she who led me back to the material
world
wedding jitters aren't just reserved for
real weddings
according to robert pattinson kristen
stewart was terrified when filming the
bella and edward wedding
she knew how important the scene was to
the story and was so scared that she'd
messed something up
it even made rob a little nervous she
walks out and she's absolutely terrified
i hadn't been nervous for the entire
scene before she walked down the aisle
daenerys may have been fierce while
flying her dragons but for amelia clark
it was like riding a very scary
amusement park ride
behind the scenes she's actually sitting
on a big green shell that she had to be
careful not to fall off of at all times
at least they eventually got her a
harness and
just use it do you know the scene in
game of thrones where jon snow
is being chased by the bolton cavalry
kit harrington would like
everyone to know that it wasn't a green
screen instead
kid had to stand there and actually fear
for his life just so they could get the
scene filmed
he called the experience very scary
are you scared jason madeleine pech hid
her emotions in this opening scene of
riverdale
the actress has a huge fear of deep and
large bodies of water
and ironically one of her very first
days on set she was forced to face it
i was having a panic attack no one knew
i was freaking out
i had to wear these beautiful valentinos
in the boat when i got in
so i was terrified of stepping in the
boat can you think back to the first
time you experienced seeing pennywise on
screen
come join the clown edge
you were probably pretty freaked out
well imagine having that same experience
but in person that's what happened to
the young cast of
it they weren't allowed to see alexander
skarsgard in his pennywise costume until
the moment they filmed together
their on-screen reaction is 100 percent
real
surprise one of the many jump scares in
season one of haunting of hill house
wasn't entirely scripted and terrified
actress kate siegel and elizabeth reeser
the director instructed victoria
pedretti to pop out earlier in this
scene than expected to get their real
reaction
it wasn't just jennifer garner's
character in her netflix
film who found herself saying yes to
some not ideal situations
jennifer had to face her fear of roller
coasters in the film
yesterday thanks to her fear in real
life they were able to capture some
realistic footage
is it bad that we're laughing i hated it
it went higher on the second side the
transfiguration classroom in the chamber
of secrets was
full of actual live animals well one of
those animals a monkey
absolutely petrified the young actors
while they were filming on
set apparently it was engaging in some
very inappropriate behavior
daniel radcliffe even went as far as
calling it traumatic
very well the first time michael kane
saw heath ledger in his joker costume
was the moment the cameras were rolling
that meant michael was taken aback and
even a little terrified
he'll frighten the life out of you he
did that to me the first time i saw him
i forgot every line terrifying
the conjuring story is terrifying but
actress vera farmiga did a deep dive
into the history of the warrens and all
things supernatural before taking on the
role
her research left her constantly in fear
while on set
she was so spooked that she expected to
see real-life supernatural occurrences
like children levitating every corner
she turned
in pitch perfect 3 rebel wilson had to
continuously film a 20-foot jump which
wasn't great for her fear of heights
each time the director said action
she was terrified i know i seem really
tough but i am afraid of heights
i had to do this 20-foot jump 10 times
and each time i was petrified
jennifer aniston had a traumatizing
underwater experience when she was five
leading to this scene she filmed in her
film cake to be unbearable
the director needed her to continuously
keep submerging herself
under the water and for jennifer it was
near impossible
it took me 30 takes i will never do that
again
for ryan reynolds every day on set of
his film buried was a struggle
one of his biggest fears is
claustrophobia and he was constantly in
a confined space on set
it triggered him emotionally and what
you see on screen is really how he was
feeling
it was tough buried was really really
tough
emotionally and physically we're hoping
that scarlett johansson at least
knew what she was signing up for when
she auditioned for a film called we
bought a zoo
but that didn't stop her from having a
huge fear of the birds that were on set
something about wings and beaks and the
flapping i am terrified of them
but she got through it in the end
congratulations
in other words fear on a movie set isn't
always a bad thing for performance
sometimes it improves a scene we just
can't believe that in some of these
scenes we couldn't even detect that they
were terrified
it just proves how amazing these actors
are
could you sense that the actors were
terrified in these scenes
[Music]